because we're so close to the border i
want to add some tex-mex flavors to my
menu at the final cook
i'm about to meet an expert who still
makes the traditional
corn tortillas today which may just give
me that edge over justin
emmanuel gordon how you doing very well
things but how are you
great welcome to texas oh my lord good
to see you too emmanuel chavez is a
local chef whose life is fueled
by his passion for the traditional
tortilla super important
you can't come to texas and not
represent the other side of the border
and i'm gonna show you how to do it
please we're gonna do it together
please please please emmanuel starts
with a lesson
on how to make the perfect masa a dough
made from corn
so right here we have conical it's a
native seat from mexico
this is our base for our tortilla turns
into masa so the idea is to grind it
correctly so it's a blue
it is a blue corn and it stays blue wow
that's gorgeous we're gonna make blue
tortillas
should we start yes sorry you're gonna
grab a little handful of these konica
you're gonna start from the top gotcha
you're gonna do some almost like a pasta
motion
so with your wrist you're gonna roll
forward and then roll backwards
there you go there you go wow
they're incredibly uh powdery now isn't
it that's the that's the massacre
you're doing great the challenge for me
was the the grinding
so you're sort of rolling spinning
rolling and spinning it's all in the
wrist
man that's incredible grab a little bit
and just make it into a ball
nice little ball it looks dry but it's
actually quite wet
yeah no it's perfect yeah it's a perfect
masa that's lovely a great job
masa made and with emmanuel's brisket
already simmering i'm dying to make a
tortilla
but we're not done before we finish our
tacos we need one more ingredient one
more ingredient i'll show you where is
it at
seriously the baking pepper peking
pepper
the national pepper from texas wow
bloody hell are they uh longhorns texas
long haul
yeah oh my god they're gorgeous huh man
they are beautiful look at those
how majestic are they they're big boys
too
okay let's not get them uh disturbed but
let's go
okay where are those right there in that
corner
that's them there that's it right here
they're gorgeous aren't they that's
incredible how they just
grow wild like that huh so red and green
red and green yeah
red super hot right yeah i'm gonna try a
green one just to be safe
go from there
yeah man
texas right there so the idea is to
lightly press them and then finish them
in the stew
absolutely that's what we're gonna do
excellent
all of them in there yeah peppers
crushed
and added to the brisket it's time to
finish making the tortillas
that should be fine yeah that yeah
that's beautiful actually you have to
rotate it that's perfect
look at that yeah you got him wow
and straight into the skillet yeah are
you gonna do one motion don't don't toss
it just
gently gently love it make love to it
there you go wow look at the color of
those things
as soon as you see the edges start to to
cook a little bit like that one yes i'll
give it a flip
just flip it with your fingers yeah just
ready to flip
tortilla's finished it's time to taste
the fruits of our labour
my god that is incredible
wow what a delicious combination but it
starts with the base
the foundation of the tex-mex tortilla
nothing's disintegrating i'm slightly
nervous about how thin it was it's so
pliable and the starchiness is absorbing
all that
incredible flavor from the brisket
getting to grips with a
authentic tortilla for me makes that
dish
transform into something even more
delicious i'd love to use these for the
final cook
absolutely would you mind no matter your
style thank you thanks good luck
[Music]
you